[Musique]
nous sommes en 1966 une équipe de
télévision partait sur les routes de
France à la rencontre de trois jeunes
frères prodiges du jazz manouche
16 ans René guitare d'accompagnement 14
ans et Gilbert le batteur 12 ans près de
60 ans plus tard on a retrouvé Koko et
Gilbert du côté d'Avignon ainsi que René
de passage à Paris et ensemble il vous
raconte ce qu'ils sont devenus bonjour
je m'appelle René briabal j'ai 72 ans je
suis guitariste bonjour je m'appelle
coco Briaval j'ai 74 ans voilà c'est
pareil moi je joue de la guitare je
m'appelle Gilbert Briaval j'ai
aujourd'hui j'ai 71 ans et je joue de la
batterie nationale 7 route des vacances
caravane de véhicule et pourtant la
famille Brial ne part pas en vacances
elle va camper certes mais pas comme
tout le monde
parmi les siens
les gitans c'est vraiment
ils m'ont vendre de revoir ça
[Musique]
et mon frère Gilbert
on dirait un petit moineau c'est la
première fois que je revois cette
archers
donc qui était vraiment en famille avec
Django Reinhardt mais vous savez dans
les gens du voyage on est pratiquement
tous en famille on retrouve beaucoup de
nom de famille
ma tante c'est un tel mon cousin c'est
lui et on se retrouve comme ça pour eux
tous
il y a encore une certaine manière de
jouer qui n'appartient aux enfants
mon enfant c'était la liberté on était
bien et on est toujours bien mais on
peut faire
de la musique d'être avec les parents
tout ça c'était bonheur c'était
l'aventure
nous on est des simples
ma mère ils ont voyagé toute leur vie
voilà mais elle savait ni lire ni écrire
donc pendant 6 ans
ils ont arrêté de voyager pour qu'on
soit scolarisé correctement en ne
faisait que de chanter écouter la radio
tout le temps et elle voulait chanter
donc ma grand-mère n'a jamais voulu donc
elles sont faits c'est qu'on fasse la
musique vous avez trois fils tous les
trois magiciens avez-vous une
responsabilité dans leur vocation
ça fait drôle
parce que Coco lui c'est il a appris la
musique c'est-à-dire il a commencé par
le piano non mon père n'était pas
musicien mais il
jouait de la bonne si peu il chantait il
avait une bonne oreille donc la musique
de jazz lui plaisait et quand on a fait
ça pour lui c'était quelque chose
extraordinaire
[Musique]
coucou vous n'avez pas toujours joué
comme ça non il y a combien de temps
vous avez commencé ça fait trois ans
maintenant qu'est-ce que c'est pour
votre Django Reinhard
gros c'est sûr mais je me suis fait
aussi mon style
bon on a fini par trouver un professeur
et on a eu la chance pour nous parce
qu'on trouvait pas de professeur de jazz
donc voilà depuis on a appris comme ça
tu as commencé à prendre la guitare oui
j'ai commencé pendant deux semaines deux
semaines pourquoi tu fais pas ça
j'ai commencé à prendre la différence
j'étais petit là
un peu et à ma sortie cette fameuse
boîte elle a écrit sa boîte à couture
elle m'a tout vidé la boîte à couture
elle m'a dit ouais je vais apprendre là
dessus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on voit qu'on est doué mais quand tu te
vois faire ça déjà ça veut dire que tu
as le don déjà après il y a eu le
travail après je suis content de moi il
y a pas si longtemps que ça non non faut
pas croire
alors le départ assassine curiosité pour
autant et on connaissait un homme qui
s'occupait du festival de jazz il avait
dit à mes parents il y a la maison
Philippe ce qui descend à Arles il vient
d'enregistrer un groupe de folklorique
et il avait dit à ma mère surtout dès
qu'ils ont fini de jouer il faut que
vous attaquez à jouer même que les
portes sont pas ouverts on a fait ça et
de suite ils ont dit mais qui c'est ces
gens-là et là on a saisi un contrat
d'ailleurs quelques jours après
[Musique]
on a fait l'Olympia donc des premières
parties de Juliette Gréco Polnareff
Polnareff c'est vrai bon Otis Redding en
dernier ou avec qui on devait finir sa
tournée justement que lui il a mal fini
parce qu'il est tombé avec l'avion et on
devrait être avec lui normalement donc
après les années 80 on s'est pas mal
baladé on était deux fois Pakistan on a
été aussi en Amérique
mais peut-être au 30e disque je croise
[Musique]
on a dit à nos enfants qu'on avait été
filmés en 1966 ou 67 je me rappelle plus
mais c'est eux qui les ont découvert
l'archive de Lina et après nous l'ont
dit vous êtes dessus c'est un copain
guitariste de Paris qui m'a dit il y a
un documentaire sur sur ton père et tes
ongles et ça m'a beaucoup beaucoup
touché c'est ce document de revoir aussi
mes grands-parents tout jeune parce que
moi je les ai jamais trop connus de tout
jeune alors moi je chante
oui j'aime bien
[Musique]
pensé le métier avec ma famille avec mes
oncles mon père il y avait aussi mon
cousin Zézé au saxophone j'ai joué de la
clarinette à l'âge de 12 ans et
maintenant je joue du sac alto et du
ténor moi j'ai commencé à apprendre la
guitare donc avec mon père puissant puis
ensuite c'est René qui m'a appris la
guitare on a grandi dedans quelque part
après voilà on s'est mis on continue on
le rêve musical
[Musique]
ici nous sommes à cabane c'est un petit
village à côté d'Avignon c'est là où je
vis avec ma compagne et à côté de coco
on vit pas ensemble on est tous à côté
les uns des autres
moi Gilbert il a 3 enfants première son
mais pas de musicienne des mélomanes et
je suis pas à aigri
j'ai un petit chiffre et j'espère que il
sortira quelque chose peut-être de là
c'est comme les miennes des petits-fils
j'espère que ça viendra aussi musicien
on espère toujours moi ce que je ce que
j'ai ressenti dans cette vidéo c'est
selon cette concentration cette envie de
jouer et donner à fond
pas
[Musique]
je regrette
on rencontre du monde la première chose
qu'on vous demande qu'est-ce que tu veux
boire qu'est-ce que vous mangez ce soir
on dit pas faire une rouillée qui est ma
sœur pour moi c'est le plus beau métier
du monde même si des fois on a fait des
galères des fois on est mal payés
d'ailleurs on voyage avec notre musique
donc on n'a pas arrêté j'espère que vous
rouler encore un moment
[Musique]